did you not hear that John and I run
Christmas I know I know I'd share an oz
board man she hates you guys just on my
show and I was like wait why I was like
people got so mad because we changed but
he had this idea because the me to
movement they pulled they did it's cold
outside from any radio like a lot of
radio stations at Christmas well I love
that oh yeah but then Sharon assumed
that you guys burned them all in the
backyard or something that can never
listen to the original idea and both
John and I've actually cut baby it's
cold outside the original and we like
the original but we noticed that a lot
of people didn't so we're like oh let's
just give him another option or whatever
and apparently we killed Christmas nice
I mean I literally woke up the next day
and I was like I can't have my creepy
song it's not the date-rape dream baby
songs I was like and honestly the
original doesn't even offend me I just
was like cool we'll do another version
exactly yeah like I'm not offended or
like I hear it all hard to offend me I
wasn't mad about the song I don't care
what you guys I own there could be like
oh I hate this now oh my god get oh yeah
it's so weird
yeah she actually said and she means it
like she loves y'all that's why I
thought was still weird like she took it
so personal like I just thought it was
weird like but but here's the thing I
actually love her I do I she came on
here and I was like I love her I think
she's so funny but then I was like we
didn't kill Christmas they're nicer live
and well cuz I'm trying to understand it
because I'm like there are so many
issues in the world right now I mean no
like an iPod guy creepy song it's so
weird anyway I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this